well guys not a very good day not a very
good day at all and this is something
that I don't normally do I don't
normally talk to you guys about
celebrities who have passed because I
feel that it's almost like sacred ground
or something like you just don't want to
tread there the only time to ever done
that before was with Roger Ebert and
that's obviously because he had a
humongous impact on my life and he meant
a lot to me in regards to what I do but
unfortunately today Robin Williams did
pass away at age 63 from an apparent
suicide it's not confirmed yet but the
thing is I've been trying to figure out
how I can I want to talk about this a
little bit because I feel that it would
be therapeutic for me and maybe it'll be
therapeutic for other people out there
who are feeling the same way I do you
see this is what my day was so far I
went to the screening for the giver and
it was pouring rain flash flood you know
I almost didn't make it there when I got
there I realized that it's actually not
starting at 7:00 what starts at 7:00 was
a red carpet broadcast live where you
got to see the stars you know come up
and talk to people about the film then
you got to watch the movie
Jeff Bridges comes up to the podium and
he just starts crying and we were
curious about and he just says my friend
just died and the entire theater gasped
when the news reporter said yes Robin
Williams has been reported passed away
and it was really hard to see the dude
himself up there just breaking down they
made the Fisher King together Robin
Williams and Jeff Bridges and I just sat
there with the wind taken out of me
because this guy meant so much to me
growing up and I want to talk a little
bit about that and talk about some of
the ways that he affected me so
positively see when I was a kid in
school I was the lowest of the low I'm
talking here's the popular kids here's
the middle kids here's the uncool
and then there's me I got made fun of
every day I was always the punchline of
whatever joke someone was making
overweight I weighed like 230 pounds I
weigh about 190 now and I'm six four
like I was five nine five ten then and I
weighed 230 so imagine that super uncool
very unpopular nerdy kid I'm still nerdy
but I mean no friends really in school
at all
and I had a few friends outside a school
that really helped me enjoy my childhood
but Robin Williams movies and him as an
actor and as a comedian brought so much
joy to my life in that time I'll never
forget the first time I saw Aladdin and
I automatically wanted a genie as a
friend and not just because you could
get wishes but because it was like a
friend you could just wish up and and
there he was and I mean uh Aladdin
he was amazing as the genie as the voice
of the genie he was incredible I can't
tell you how many times I watched hook
growing up I adore that movie and to
this day I still think it's very
underrated but it meant so much to me as
a kid because it just it strengthened my
imagination it made me want to go to
other places it made me want to
experience new things and a lot of that
was due to Robin Williams portrayal of
this man who was so stilted and then
just experienced this incredible joy
realizing who he really was and I know
it's not considered one of his greatest
films but growing up Jumanji was always
on replay in my house I had the VHS case
with the clamshell cover and I would
watch Jumanji all the time and I
remember the special effects being
amazing at the time but now they're
pretty terrible but nevertheless Robin
Williams portrayal of some of these
characters as I grew up really meant so
much to me because even if you're not a
fan of some of these movies you can't
help but smile when you see that guy he
has the most warm and infectious smile
in all of his movies and you just can't
help but smile back it wasn't until I
was an adult that I saw films like good
morning Vietnam and I saw his incredible
improv ability if you ever saw inside
the Actors Studio his guest stint on
that show was incredible it was
basically like an improv stand-up
routine despite the fact that he was
talking about his
life I remember the first time I saw
awakenings with Robin Williams and
Robert DeNiro it was a movie about a
doctor who went beyond the generally
conceived as okay boundaries to try to
experiment on someone who was catatonic
and that movie inspired me a lot in
regards to looking at acting very
differently because that was one of the
first times growing up where I saw
someone who is primarily viewed as as a
funny guy be able to deliver such an
incredibly heartfelt and real
performance as a doctor and of course
DeNiro was great in the film and
watching those two legends act in the
scene was also incredible but that movie
did really have a profound impact on me
now I don't usually like to get too
personal in my videos because I find
that whenever I do people just want to
rip you to shreds
you know I experienced a lot of bullying
in school like I said and I've
experienced the same thing on the
Internet
it happens and I have no real
understanding of why it just does and
being able to escape into some of Robin
Williams films growing up really helped
me deal with that a lot but there's one
that I've been leaving out because it's
one that's perhaps had the most profound
effect on me and that was Good Will
Hunting and as I say I don't like to get
too personal in my videos and I'm not
going to do too much editing in this one
because I feel that my best way to
describe how I feel is just to show you
I dealt with a lot of guilt growing up I
had a certain period of my life I blamed
myself for a lot of things I told myself
that I that a lot of things were my
fault that weren't because
I have a guilt complex I tend to blame
myself for things that aren't my fault
and it's something that I've dealt with
my whole life and I went through a
period when I became an adult where I
was really confused about my place in
life and I didn't really know which path
to take and I saw a film called Good
Will Hunting and there's a scene in Good
Will Hunting where Robin Williams
continuously says to Matt Damon over and
over again it's not your fault it's not
your fault
and he's like no I don't think you
understand it really isn't your fault
because Matt Damon's character blamed
himself for so many different problems
that he was dealing with and that other
people were dealing with and he
shouldn't blame himself for things that
are outside of his control and it just
had an absurd effect on me where I
suddenly realized that I was doing the
same thing I was blaming myself for
things that weren't my fault and I
realized that I really need to move
forward in life and forget about certain
things that were weighing me down and
very rarely will I ever say that an
actor or an actress was perfect in a
scene but Robin Williams was perfect in
that scene and I mean completely
flawless in every way he embodied that
character and I think it really meant a
lot to him because I know that as a
person he dealt with a lot of similar
issues and I have his performance in
that film in that script to think for
being able to move on in my life from a
kind of dark path and I thank anyone in
my life who's stood by me through that
but going back to the joyous aspect of
Robin Williams's career
mrs. Doubtfire I mean just able to
embody
a character where you were like it's not
gonna work man
don't take that part but he made it work
he made it seem so effortless he just
had such an infectious laugh an
infectious smile a smile that made you
want to like and care about that guy and
he really genuinely did seem like he
enjoyed making other people happy and
that was something that he did so well
and I wish that he had known how many
people just truly how many people loved
him because I did love him I've never
even met him and just from seeing his
acting and his stand-up I just
he was so inspiring to me and other
people who are gravitating towards
comedy I know a lot of comedians and and
they're just devastated by this because
this guy inspired so many people and I
don't want to dwell too much on the
sadness of of this event but I want to
bring out just how much he really did
mean to a lot of people so guys if you
have a movie or an event or anything
relating to him that really did help you
or that meant something to you comment
below and let me know what it is because
maybe we can all just start like a group
therapy session in which we just we help
each other feel better about this
situation guys I know this has been a
different video and I don't normally do
videos like this but I meant everything
that I said and I hope that in some way
it had a good effect on you as well
because it definitely made me feel a
little bit better about this annoying
stupid situation but it is what it is
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I'm not going to do my
signature catchphrase because I feel
that it's a little silly I'm just going
to say thanks for watching guys and I'll
see you soon